hey come on get your stuff let's
[Music]
go let's try that
again a we week ago I spent my life
racing against time I'm going to help
you out today okay trying to save people
who are running out of it until one
moment changed
everything come on Welcome Back to the
land that we're
living I don't understand what's
happening I've been having
Vision I knew he was going to
die I think I'm see seeing the
future New York City is a whole new
level of crazy these days what do you
want
me New York City is a whole new level of
crazy these days this is an emergency
get off the train that man's trying to
kill you why who are you what is going
on I can see the
future
what the hell she didn't see that coming
that's not how it
works I've seen that man before so who
is he Ezekiel Sims he was in the Amazon
with my mom when she was researching
spiders right before she
died wait I recognize you you live in my
building you're the paramedic yeah you
almost ran me
over you don't think this is weird how
we're all
connected it's honestly like the least
weird thing that's happened all
day you have no idea what those girls
have
come I think he can see into the future
are he's trying to change what
happens J you get
down why aren't you scared of me why do
you care your future was almost so
different if you want to live you have
to trust
me get
ready
now you're showing off maybe a
little